الى اوروبا للحديث عن ابرز الاحداث في
القاره الاوروبيه ينضم الينا في الاستوديو
زميليت مزار مراسل صباح العربيه كل عام
وانت بخير لايف اخر حلقه في صباح العربيه
نتحدث فيها اليوم عن احداث اوروبا بدايه
تفضل
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير لكم وكل عام والبهجه والسعاده
على وجوه المشاهد العربي
شو بدنا نحكي بدنا نحكي مثلا اذا بدانا من
اسبانيا والبرتغال للاسف الحراره
اسبانيا مع العلم ما نحكي شويه ايجابيه
بعد شويه ولكن انه بنعرفه انه اسبانيا
فيها تصحر ونعرف انه قاموا بتشجير ادت
مناطق لزراعه غابات جديده اذا صحت تعبير
ولكن الذي حصل انا بعض تلك الغابات طبعا
حرقت الاسف بسبب التغيير المناخي وبعض
الافتعالات في هذه في هذه في هذه البلد
دين ولكن تعرفوا الشجره حتى تنمو بدها 12
سنه و12 سنه سنين كثير يعني ايام كثير
ولكن مع التغيير المناخي والتصحر اللي
حكينا عنه قبل شويه راح يكون هذا المظهر
همم صعب شويه الى ترجع الغابات
الاسبانيه كما كانت وحتى تساعد على قله
التصحر الذي بدا من سرقوستا سرقوستا في
هذه المنطقه شمال اسبانيا ويمتد حتى فرنسا
فلذلك طبعا هاي الاحداث كانت ابرز ما حدث
في اسبانيا واذا حكينا عن فرنسا فرنسا
طبعا شهدت عده مظاهرات لحد مؤخرا ولكن
تبقى باريس باريس
رجعت الحياه ما بعد كرونا الى وضعها
الطبيعي صار فيه سنواته شوكولا عم نتذكر
كيف حكينا عن الشوكولاته في فرنسا كيف انه
عاده الحياه الى الشانزليزيه عاد قوس
النصر
يضيء انواره بالوان مختلفه دائما حسب
الحدث تماما كما يحدث في برج خليفه عندما
يكون في حدث معين يضيء هذا البرج همم هذا
القوس انواره وشاهدنا كيف باريس رجعت حتى
صيفا ااه ضفاف نهر السين همم تكثرها همم
المشاه والباربيكي والبكنيك والاجواء
الحلوه وطبعا دائما الايجابيه الحلو
بالفرنسيين يا جماعه مش لاقيني عاجب باريس
دائما ينظر الى الجزء الايجابي من الموضوع
مع العلم انه صارت احداث كتيره طبعا حكينا
قبل شوي واذا حكينا اقتصاديا طبعا الازمه
الاقتصاديه اكيد اثرت بس انا بدي اخذها من
الشيء ايجابي انه صار الناس يلتموا مع بعض
اكثر في بيت بدل ما يعمل كل واحد مثلا
الكريسماس همم
مطول معك اليوم ونكمل بره لا راح نكمل على
الهواء وبره الهوا كمان بس خلينا كمان
نستذكر ابرز احداث الرياضه في عام 20 22
بعدين نرجع لك بدنا نتذكر المونديال كاس
العالم الذي ربحه العرب
يعني براي انه
[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بعديل في مفاجاه في حدا الثاني
ليث
[موسيقى]
عيد ميلادك انا بعيدا عن المونديال وبعيده
شكرا
طيب ليس غطيت المونديال حديثنا اكثر عن
ابرز الاحداث الرياضيه
المونديال انا برايي اللي صار بالمونديال
ما بنعاد يعني الفوز العربي ما كان سهل
خصوصا مع الازمات اللي بنشوفها بالعالم
العربي شفنا كيف المجتمع العربي اذكر
تماما هذا الشخص السوداني لما اجى جنبي
صار يبكي على الهواء لما ربح الفريق
المنتخب المغربي بقياده الركراكي احد
المباريات اذكر تماما الشاب الاردني لما
جاء جنبي قال لي بلاد العرب اوطانكم باسلم
الهوى ولا راويه بالنشره ما لقيت غير على
الهدوء انا بسلم الهواء بلاد العرب اوطاني
من الشامي لبغداد ومن نجدا الى يمنا الى
مصر فقط طوالي كان كثير حلو وهذا الاجواء
طبعا انا حكيت لكم اياها دار الهوى اكثر
واحد تبوسه رفعوا لي اكثر من ميسي وانا
حاسه كاس العالم من كثر مشجعين كانوا
مبسوطين على على فوز العرب في في كاس
العالم في مونديال قطر والتنظيم بقطر على
فكره كان مميز يعني شيء عن جد
بتمنى لك للخير وان شاء الله تكون سنه
افضل وافضل يعني بس في كلمه بتحب توجهها
بخصوص 20 22 كيف مرت عليك على الصعيد شخصي
اه سعيد شخصي كان كثير تحديات ومغامرات
خصوصا بالتغطيات طلعت موزونه همم بس انه
عنجد كان كان شيء حلو انه الواحد هيك يشوف
كيف يتعرف على ثقافات من باب اخر ليس
سياحيه للاسف قد تكون مرات ازمات مثل ما
شفنا باوكانيا
بس اتمنى على الجميع ان تكون هذا ان يكون
هذا العام العام الجديد مليء بالبهجه
والسعاده ودائما بقول الواحد هو اللي
بيخلق السعاده اذا ابتسمت متاكد انه بيكون
الابتسامه طوال العام شكرا شكرا جزيلا
شكرا